This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Just on the horizon, you probably can't quite make it out in Shasha. This is Andy Baharman, recording himself with his phone as he stands on a cargo ship off the coast of Shasha, a city in the United Arab Emirates. It's in some ways an adelic setting. It's 40 odd degrees, sea is calm, the sky is blue. Andy is the regional director at an organization called Mission to Sea Fairs. In part of his job is to deliver things like rice, blankets, water, and sim cards to workers who are trapped on abandoned cargo ships. It is literally me and typically one of the member of our team on a small speedboat, pulling up alongside and climbing up a 15 foot rope ladder to get to the ship.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。就在地平线上，你在沙迦可能看不太清。这是安迪·巴哈曼（Andy Baharman），他站在阿拉伯联合酋长国沙迦海岸外的一艘货轮上，用手机录下自己的声音。从某些方面来说，这是一个田园诗般的环境。气温四十多度，海面平静，天空湛蓝。安迪是“海员使命”（Mission to Seafarers）组织的一名区域总监。他的工作之一，就是给那些被困在遭遗弃货轮上的工人运送大米、毯子、水和手机卡等物品。通常情况下，就是我和我们团队的一名成员，坐着一艘小型快艇靠过去，然后顺着一根 15 英尺长的绳梯爬上船。
In some cases, the people that Andy tries to help have been stuck on these abandoned vessels without enough supplies for months or even years. And we're loading provisions yet again onto this vessel that's been here now for more than two years. Yeah, we've all been unlocked down around different parts of the world. Just multiply that by, you know, ten and you'll get a sense of what these guys are facing all the time. I mean, I would sometimes say it's like prison, but you don't know how long
在某些情况下，安迪试图帮助这些人被困在这些被抛弃的船只上，没有足够的物资，长达数月甚至数年。我们正在再次将物资装上这艘已经停在这里两年多的船。是的，我们都在世界不同地方经历过封锁。只要把那个时间乘以十，你就能体会到这些人一直在面对什么。我的意思是，我有时会说这就像监狱，但你不知道
the sentence is. Right now, there are about 50 of these situations on the International Transport Federation's official database. But a lot of these cases go unreported, and so the real number is probably much higher. That's producer Alex Etaq, who brought us this story from the podcast, Croning Cultures. Andy works mostly in the United Arab Emirates,
刑期有多长。目前，在国际运输工人联合会的官方数据库中，大约有 50 起这样的情况。但其中许多案件并未被报道，因此真实数字可能要高得多。这是制作人亚历克斯·埃塔克（Alex Atack），他为我们带来了这个来自播客节目《克朗文化》（Kerning Cultures）的故事。安迪主要在阿拉伯联合酋长国工作，
but there are abandon ships all over the world, particularly in the Middle East. And the people on them do describe feeling like they're in prison, surrounded on all sides by water and unable to leave because of the strange legal nomads land that exist for workers on these ships. This is Mehmet Galshin. He spoke to us in Turkish and we had an actor
但世界各地到处都有被抛弃的船只，尤其是在中东。船上的人确实形容感觉自己就像在监狱里，四周都被水包围，由于这些船上工人们所处的奇怪的法律无人区而无法离开。这是穆罕默德·加尔辛（Mehmet Galsin）。他用土耳其语对我们说话，我们请了一位演员
voice his lines in English. On December 17th, 2019, I joined the ship. The ship that I stayed on as prisoner. When the Met first boarded a cargo ship called the Keenan Metae in 2019, he thought he was signing up for a pretty standard seven-month contract. Then he'd be back home with his four-year-old daughter and his dog. The Keenan Mettae employed 24 other seafarers. That's the industry term for these cargo ship workers. And Mehmet was third in command just below the captain and the first officer.
用英语为他的台词配音。2019年12月17日，我登上了这艘船。这艘我作为囚犯呆在上面的船。穆罕默德（Mehmet）在 2019 年首次登上了一艘名为“基南·麦塔号”（Ceren Methe）的货轮时，他以为自己签的是一份相当标准的七个月合同。然后他就可以回家陪伴他四岁的女儿和他的狗了。“基南·麦塔号”上还雇佣了其他 24 名海员。这是业内对这些货轮工人的称呼。而穆罕默德是仅次于船长和大副的第三负责人。
At first everything was good. I had everybody's support as my crew. Everybody followed me. hierarchies are actually a crucial part of what keeps work running smoothly on a ship. The crew is in a constant battle to keep seawater from eroding the vessel, and they work in a grueling schedule, cleaning, painting, and de-rusting everything, and then doing it all again. My Met had no idea the calamity that was in store for him, but in retrospect, there were a few red flags, like sometimes the workers didn't get paid on time, and the ship, which was built in 1990, was a little rundown. It was an old ship, it wasn't a very well kept ship from the beginning.
起初一切都很好。作为我的船员，我得到了所有人的支持。所有人都听从我的指挥。等级制度实际上是保持船上工作顺利进行的关键部分。船员们一直在与海水侵蚀船只进行斗争，他们按着繁重的日程工作，清洁、油漆、除锈一切，然后再把这一切重来一遍。穆罕默德完全没有预料到等待着他的灾难，但回想起来，有一些危险信号，比如有时工人没有按时拿到工资，而且这艘建于 1990 年代的船有点破旧。这是一艘旧船，从一开始就不是一艘保存得很好的船。
It was in bad shape. And then on what was supposed to be the last leg of Momet's trip, the ship pulled into a port at the mouth of the Suez Canal in Egypt, with around 7,000 tons of cement to deliver. But when they arrived at the port, they were told by the staff manager that the owner of their ship, a Turkish company called Bloodwind Marine SA, didn't have the money to pay their salaries or the port fees, and that they'd have to wait. Momet hadn't been paid since January, and now it was June. So he and some other crew members decided to protest by stopping a lot of the basic maintenance work
它的状况很糟糕。然后，在穆罕默德的航程本该是最后一程的那天，这艘船驶入了埃及苏伊士运河口的港口，船上载有大约 7,000 吨待交付的水泥。但当他们抵达港口时，员工经理告诉他们，他们船只的拥有者——一家名为 Bloodwind Marine SA 的土耳其公司——没有钱支付他们的薪水或港口费用，他们必须等待。穆罕默德自一月以来就没拿到工资，而现在已经是六月了。因此，他和一些其他船员决定通过停止许多基础维护工作来进行抗议
that they were doing to keep the ship in reasonable shape. They told us, look, this will bankrupt us. What you're doing, the owners in a situation where he can't pay his debts, don't do this. Mehmet says that the owners made various threats in text messages to the crew. They said these things aren't easy, you'll be left in a very bad situation in there, of course they threatened. Also they did a lot of ganging up, they set the Egyptian port officials on us, they told us if you stop work, they cleared the captain, the second officer and the head engineer,
他们一直在做这些工作来使船只保持在合理的状况。他们对我们说，听着，这会让我们破产的。你们在做的事，会让船东陷入无法偿还债务的境地，别这么做。穆罕默德说，船东在给船员的短信中发出了各种威胁。他们说这些事情可不容易，你们会在那里陷入非常糟糕的境地，他们当然进行了威胁。此外，他们还进行了很多串通，他们让埃及港口官员来对付我们，他们告诉我们，如果你们停止工作，他们就会给船长、二副和大管轮洗白，
as terrorists, we'll charge you with terrorism and throw you in jail. Eventually though, the owners just went silent. They stopped communicating with the ship entirely. They started not answering our calls, so they left us, they abandoned us. They become abandoned because that word, abandoned actually takes on its real meaning, nobody cares about them,
诬陷你们为恐怖分子，我们要以恐怖主义罪起诉你们，把你们扔进监狱。不过最终，船东只是陷入了沉默。他们完全停止了与船只的联系。他们开始不接我们的电话，所以他们抛弃了我们，他们遗弃了我们。他们被抛弃了，因为“被抛弃”这个词实际上具有了它真正的含义，没有人关心他们，
and they are truly abandoned by their state, by everybody else. This is Laleh Halili, a professor of international politics at Queen Mary University in London. She just finished writing a book about the shipping industry in the Gulf called Synos of War and Trade. I mean, this is kind of like a very basic, maybe stupid question, but like, why can't they kind of just get off the ship at the port? It's not a stupid question at all.
他们真正被自己的国家和所有人抛弃了。这是拉勒·哈利利（Laleh Halili），伦敦玛丽女王大学国际政治教授。她刚刚写完一本关于海湾航运业的书，书名叫《战争与贸易的罪恶》（Sinews of War and Trade）。我的意思是，这听起来有点像一个非常基础、甚至有点愚蠢的问题，但比如，为什么他们不能直接在港口下船呢？这绝对不是一个愚蠢的问题。
So there are several things. One is the international treaty obligations, requires affairs to stay with a ship for safety reasons, etc. etc. And if they get off the ship, they actually forfeit their wages. So in many instances, CFERRs end up having to stay on the ship if they want to be able to get paid. Ship abandonment tends to happen with smaller companies operating on really tight profit margins. They run into financial trouble and suddenly they can't come up with the money to pay the costs involved in running a ship, fuel, port fees and seafarers salaries.
所以有几件事。一是国际条约义务要求海员为了安全原因等留在船上。如果他们下船，他们实际上将失去工资。因此，在许多情况下，海员如果想拿到工资，最终只能留在船上。船只被遗弃往往发生在那些利润率非常薄的小公司身上。他们陷入了财务困境，突然拿不出钱来支付运营船只所需的费用，包括燃料、港口费用和海员薪水。
Generally, seafarers can make anywhere from $50,000 to $6,000 a month. It's more than most of them feel they can make in their home countries, which is why they're willing to put up with a job where they won't see their families from on end. And a lot of sea fairers take out loans against the money they expect to earn working on ships. So in some cases, they start these contracts already in debt. Beyond wanting to wait on the ship to hopefully eventually get paid, LaLay says that a lot of countries just won't allow these abandoned seafarers to come on to land. If they've not been paid their wages, and if they don't have a ticket home,
通常情况下，海员每月的收入在 5,000 到 6,000 美元之间。这比他们觉得在自己国家能赚到的要多，这就是为什么他们愿意忍受一份几个月见不到家人的工作。许多海员甚至会用他们预计在船上工作赚到的钱来贷款。因此，在某些情况下，他们在开始这些合同的时候就已经负债累累了。除了想要留在船上以期最终拿到工资之外，拉勒说，许多国家根本不允许这些被遗弃的海员上岸。如果他们没有拿到工资，并且如果没有回家的车票，
that means that essentially these are going to be people that are abandoned indigents in a state that doesn't probably want to support them. Essentially, no one wants to claim responsibility for these abandoned crews. And when the owners disappear, it can be hard to figure out what higher entity to appeal to, because the ships are often flying what's called flags of convenience. I mean, it's a terrible thing, but essentially what it is intended to do is to avoid regulation and to avoid any kind of good service or virtuous treatment of the environment or the workers. Until the 1920s, ships generally had to follow the regulations on working conditions and pay and taxes
这意味着这些人本质上将成为被遗弃的无依无靠之人，而一个可能并不想支持他们的国家。本质上，没有人愿意为这些被抛弃的船员承担责任。而当船东消失时，可能很难弄清楚该向哪个更高层级的实体上诉，因为这些船只通常悬挂所谓的方便旗。我的意思是，这是一件可怕的事情，但它的本质目的是为了规避监管，并避免对环境或工人进行任何形式的优质服务或人道对待。直到 20 世纪 20 年代，船只通常必须遵守关于工作条件、薪酬和税收的规定，
according to their country of origin. So a British ship flying a British flag, they'd follow UK laws, American ship, American laws. But in the American prohibition in the 1920s, ship flying a British flag, they'd follow UK laws, American ship, American laws. But in the American prohibition in the 1920s, ship owners started to realize that they could evade US laws against transporting alcohol if they registered their ships in Panama. And by doing it this way,
根据他们的原籍国。因此，悬挂英国国旗的英国船只将遵循英国法律，美国船只遵循美国法律。但在 20 世纪 20 年代的美国禁酒令期间，船东开始意识到，如果他们在巴拿马注册船只，他们就可以逃避美国关于运输酒精的法律。通过这种方式，
they also avoided a bunch of US taxes and minimum wage requirements. More and more ships started to do the same, and so flags of convenience became a thing. Today, around three quarters of ships worldwide fly a flag of convenience. It isn't illegal to do this. It's not even really a loophole. It's just a norm in the shipping industry. The only ships that don't do it are the ones that do most of their business in the US and Europe where there are stricter rules. in Europe where there are stricter rules. In Mehmet's case, his ship, the Khenon Mette, was owned by a Turkish company but was registered
他们还避免了一堆美国税收和最低工资要求。越来越多的船只开始效仿，于是方便旗便应运而生。如今，全球约有四分之三的船只悬挂方便旗。这样做并不违法。这甚至算不上真正的漏洞。它只是航运业的一种常态。唯一不这样做的是那些在规则更严格的美国和欧洲开展大部分业务的船只。在欧洲有更严格的规则。就穆罕默德而言，他的船“基南·麦塔号”（Khenon Mette）归一家土耳其公司所有，但注册
under a Panamanian flag. Bloodwind Marine SA, the owner of Mehmet's ship, doesn't have a website. They aren't listed in directories, so they're basically unreachable. And by the middle of June of 2020, they'd completely stopped communicating with the crew. But Mehmet thought surely the owners aren't just going to walk away from their ship. At the end of the day, the ship was worth around $2.5 million. And what we were owed was about $120,000. So we were thinking they will give us our money.
在巴拿马国旗下。Bloodwind Marine SA 是穆罕默德那艘船的船东，它没有网站。它们没有被列在名录中，所以基本上无法联系到它们。到 2020 年 6 月中旬，它们已经完全停止与船员联系。但穆罕默德认为，船东肯定不会就这样抛弃他们的船。说到底，这艘船价值约 250 万美元。而我们被欠的薪水大约是 12 万美元。所以我们当时想，他们会给我们钱的。
Then when the company stopped answering, we thought they were bluffing the first month. The crew sat on the ship and waited, hoping for some kind of resolution. As June rolled into July, things got harder and the weather got hotter. The time wouldn't pass on the ship. It was really hard. It was unbelievably hard because you can't go out. You're always on the same quarters. And then even if you got out, it was unbelievably hard because you can't go out, you're always on the same quarters.
然后，当公司不再回复时，我们以为他们在虚张声势。第一个月，船员们坐在船上等待，希望能达成某种解决方案。随着 6 月进入 7 月，事情变得更加困难，天气也变得更热。时间在船上简直无法度过。真的很难。这简直难以置信地难，因为你不能外出。你总是待在同一个船舱里。而且即使你出去了，这也难以置信地难，因为你不能出去，你总是待在同一个船舱里。
And then even if you got out, it was really hot. I mean, really, we experienced summer heat waves there. So the humidity, the dents, the filth. The crew couldn't go onto land, but they could see the shore of Egypt shimmering on the horizon. Where we stopped, there was the desert, what can I tell you? I mean, there was nothing beautiful about it. Nearby, there was a soil that has the raw material of cement.
而且即使你能出去，天气也真的很热。我的意思是，我们在那里真的经历了夏天的热浪。所以湿度、浓密的灰尘、污垢。船员们不能上岸，但他们可以看到埃及的海岸在地平线上闪烁。我们停泊的地方只有沙漠，我能告诉你什么呢？我的意思是，那里没有任何美丽可言。附近有一片含有水泥原料的土壤。
There's a lot of that in Egypt, so they were mining that in the mountains. And they were always doing some explosions with dynamite. Like sometimes when the wind blew, the dust would get really bad. We would be all be covered in dirt. The crew kept trying to contact the ship owners to no avail. They also contacted the company that had ordered the 7,000 tons of cement on their ship to see if there was anything they could do.
埃及有很多那种东西，所以他们一直在群山中开采。他们总是用炸药进行爆破。就像有时风一吹，尘土就会变得非常糟糕。我们身上都会覆盖着泥土。船员们不断试图联系船东，但都无济于事。他们还联系了订购船上 7,000 吨水泥的公司，看看是否有他们能帮忙的。
But that didn't help either. Eventually, they also reached out to some of their own consulates in Egypt. For my mate, that was the Turkish consulate, but no one would help. As he kept on dragging on, we started to understand this series and this sort of didn't matter. The crew didn't realize it at the time, but they were entering into a kind of sunk-cost black hole. The more time that passed, the more they felt, like, all that time would be wasted if they got off the ship now
但这也没有用。最终，他们还联系了他们在埃及各自的领事馆。对穆罕默德来说，那是土耳其领事馆，但没有人肯帮忙。随着事情不断拖延，我们开始明白这种严重性以及这类事情根本不重要。船员们当时并没有意识到，但他们正在进入一个沉没成本的黑洞。时间过得越久，他们越觉得，如果现在下船却拿不到工资，
without being paid. If they could wait, there was a good chance the insurance company would pay out or the owners would be taken to court and forced to pay their salaries. This had happened in abandoned shipcases before, but it's impossible to know how long it might take and whether waiting is the right decision. And it can quickly escalate to go beyond three to six months, to 12 months, two years. And it's absolutely incredible how often that seems to happen. That's Andy Bowman again from Mission to See Ferris. Andy wasn't involved with Mehmet's ship
那么所有的时间都将白白浪费。如果他们能等下去，保险公司理赔或者船东被送上法庭并被迫支付薪水的可能性很大。以前在被遗弃船只的案例中发生过这种情况，但不可能知道这需要多长时间，以及等待是否是正确的决定。这种情况可能会迅速升级，从三到六个月，变成十二个月、两年。而且这种情况发生的频率简直令人难以置信。这是“海员使命”组织的安迪·鲍曼（Andy Bowman）。安迪没有参与穆罕默德的船，
because it wasn't in the geographic area where he works. But he's seen these cases go on for a very long time. Once it becomes a stalemate, the crew say, well, I can't go home with nothing because I've now waited 12 months, 24 months. Besides delivering basic supplies to abandoned ships, Andy also tries to track down the owners of these vessels to get them to take responsibility for their crews. But he doesn't have a ton of tools at his disposal, just the phone and emails, so it can be a very
因为它不在他工作的地理区域内。但他见过这些案例持续很长时间。一旦陷入僵局，船员们就会说，好吧，我不能什么都不拿就回家，因为我已经等了 12 个月、24 个月了。除了向被抛弃的船只提供基本物资外，安迪还试图追踪这些船只的船东，让他们对自己的船员承担责任。但他手头并没有太多工具，只有一部手机和电子邮件，所以这可能是一个非常
slow process. What do they say? What is their defence? I have definitely had cases where I've sat in a meeting with an owner. This was one specific case that happened last year with an owner in the United Arab Emirates. And he has made it absolutely clear that the seafarers are the last thing he's thinking about. He is worried about the mortgage that he has, other creditors that he has to pay, and he almost said, and he didn't quite say these, but almost, the seafarers are just a commodity, with everything else that needs to be sorted out. By August of 2020, things had gotten more dire on Momet Ship.
缓慢的过程。他们怎么说？他们的辩护是什么？我确实遇到过这样的情况，我曾与一名船东坐在一起开会。这是去年发生的一起特定案件，船东在阿拉伯联合酋长国。他明确表示，海员是他最不放在心上的事情。他担心的是他背负的按押贷款、他必须支付的其他债权人，他甚至差点说——虽然没有完全说出口，但差不多就是这个意思——海员只是一种商品，需要同其他所有需要解决的事情一起处理。到 2020 年 8 月，穆罕默德船上的情况变得更加严峻。
They couldn't pull into port to restart provisions without paying the port fees, which they didn't have. And they were running out of food. The crew was rationing. So we were distributing the food by one by one. And you get three apples, you get three apples, you get two pairs, I get one cucumber, it came to that level. I mean, in the end, there's a saying, all problems on the ship start from the kitchen.
由于没有资金支付港口费用，他们无法进港补充物资。而且他们的食物也快吃完了。船员们开始定量配给食物。所以我们按个分配食物，你拿三个苹果，你拿三个苹果，你拿两个梨，我拿一根黄瓜，事情已经到了这个地步。我的意思是，到最后，有句老话，船上的所有问题都始于厨房。
It's really true. A hunger, as you know, is the beginning of everything. I mean, people were at their boiling point. Fights were starting to come up even from... Why did you look at me that way? Why did you look at me this way? Mehmet said eventually the official hierarchies on the ship broke down.
这千真万确。如你所知，饥饿是一切的开始。我的意思是，人们都处于爆发的边缘。甚至因为……你为什么那样看着我？你为什么这样看着我？这样的原因，争吵开始出现了。穆罕默德说，最终船上的官方等级制度崩溃了。
It didn't matter who had been in charge before, there was a new order beginning to form. The superior subordinate relationship, it was, we lost that. And then racial grouping started. Everybody was hanging out with their own nationalities. And at the end there were groupings in between Everybody was hanging out with their own nationalities and at the end there were groupings in between those racial groups. I mean the Indians had different groups
以前谁负责已经不重要了，一种新的秩序开始形成。这种上下级关系，我们失去了它。然后种族群体开始出现。每个人都和自己的同国人待在一起。最后，在这些不同的种族群体之间也开始出现小团体。我的意思是，印度人内部有不同的群体，
amongst each other. The Turks had different groups amongst each other. The Ukrainians had had the same so on. So we kept on being more divided. By this point Mehmet did want to leave the ship. He was like, I don't care what happens to my salary. I just want to be off. But no one would join him, and he was scared he might be put in jail. He couldn't face going through that alone. I didn't want to do anything alone because I didn't know what would happen to me if I was alone.
土耳其人内部有不同的群体。乌克兰人也是如此，等等。所以我们变得越来越分裂。到了这个时候，穆罕默德确实想离开这艘船。他觉得，我不在乎我的薪水会怎么样。我只想离开。但没有人愿意跟他一起走，而且他害怕自己会被抓进监狱。他无法独自面对这一切。我不想独自做任何事，因为我不知道如果我独自一人，会发生什么。
I mean, I couldn't take the risk. Still, he constantly and obsessively thought about getting off the ship and concocted some irrational plans. It will get bad. You get so suffocated on the ship, you start not being able to think logically because your psychology deteriorates so much. You're thinking, what can I do? There was a beach about three miles away that he thought about swimming too, or when other Turkish ships came by,
我的意思是，我承担不起这个风险。尽管如此，他还是不断地、执着地想着要下船，并炮制了一些不理智的计划。情况会变得很糟糕。你在船上憋闷得厉害，由于心理状况恶化得太严重，你开始无法进行逻辑思考。你在想，我能做什么呢？大约三英里外有一个海滩，他曾想过游过去，或者当其他土耳其船只路过时，
he thought about somehow jumping onto one of those and stirring away, but he didn't. I was talking to my family, my sister, she was stopping me. And my friends were like, there was no need just to hang on a bit longer, this two shell pass kind of thing. And they supported me, my friends, and my family.
他曾想过某种方式跳上去并偷渡离开，但他没有这么做。我当时在和我的家人、我的姐姐通话，她在阻止我。我的朋友们也说，没必要，再坚持一会儿，这种日子总会过去的。他们支持我，我的朋友们和我的家人。
Thanks to them. I mean, that's how I hung on. The crew of the abandoned Kenan Nette did also have support from one organization, who first heard about their case shortly after they were abandoned. Let me switch off my mobile. Switch off this mobile because it never stops. It never stops. Wait, why? What's going on on it? There's messages, messages, there's requests from seafares for assistance. it. This is Muhammad Arachedi. He's the Arab world and Iran coordinator at the International Transport Workers Federation, the ITF, which is basically a labour organisation that offers
多亏了他们。我的意思是，我是这样坚持下来的。被抛弃的“基南·麦塔号”的船员确实也得到了一个组织的支援，该组织在他们被遗弃后不久就听说了他们的案子。让我关掉手机。关掉这部手机，因为它从不停歇。它从不停歇。等等，为什么？上面发生什么了？有消息，有消息，有海员要求援助的请求。
help where it can to abandon seafarers. While Andy is often on board with crews offering supplies and moral support, Muhammad is more focused on the bureaucratic end of the problem. He spends his days in an office, doggedly phoning and emailing ship owners and organizing legal cases against them. Honestly, every day I've got a good and big list to tackle. When we spoke, he just got back from dropping his kids at school.
这是穆罕默德·阿拉谢迪（Muhammad Arachedi）。他是国际运输工人联盟（ITF）的阿拉伯世界和伊朗协调员，ITF基本上是一个劳工组织，为被抛弃的海员提供力所能及的
And part of his routine each morning is to sift through all of these messages, abandon ship cases where he's been asked to help, and figure out what he can do. But obviously he can't deal with all of them at once. Like Andy, Mohamed tries to reach out to the owners of these ships. And when he can't, he'll start putting pressure
帮助。安迪经常在船上为船员提供物资和精神支持，而穆罕默德则更专注于解决问题的官僚主义方面。他终日坐在办公室里，坚持不懈地给船说电话、发邮件，并组织针对他们的法律诉讼。老实说，我每天都有长长的一大串清单要处理。我们交谈时，他刚把孩子送到学校回来。
on whatever country the ship's flag represents. But he hits a lot of dead ends or people saying that they'll look into it, but nothing happens. You insist that these people, this seafarers have no water. This is emergency, and you still receive that we are looking at it
他每天早晨的日常工作之一，就是筛选所有这些要求他帮忙的被抛弃船只案件的消息，并弄清楚他能做些什么。但很显然，他不可能同时处理所有这些事情。和安迪一样，穆罕默德试图联系这些船只的船东。当他联系不上时，他就会开始向船只悬挂国旗的那个国家施加压力。但他遇到了很多死胡同，或者听到别人说他们会去查，但什么也没有发生。
and that someone will be in touch with you. So who's the sponsor of it is this? When Muhammad first heard about Mehmet's ship, the Keenan Mete, and all of the crew abandoned on it, it was June of 2020. He reached out to Bloodwind Marine SA, which owned the ship, and he said that initially they were somewhat responsive.
你坚持说这些人，这些海员没有水。这是紧急情况，而你收到的回复仍然是我们正在调查，会有人与你联系。那么到底谁才是赞助者？当穆罕默德第一次听到关于穆罕默德的船“基南·麦塔号”以及船上所有被抛弃的船员的消息时，那是 2020 年 6 月。他联系了拥有这艘船的 Bloodwind Marine SA 公司，他说最初他们的态度还算有些回应。
Eventually, though, they completely dropped off the radar, and Muhammad didn't hear from them again. Luckily, the ship had insurance, and Mohamed started lobbying them to help. ITF put pressure. By putting pressure on the insurance company, they got us four months of pay. ITF did that. Mohamed got the insurance to cover basic supplies for the ZFIRESTUCK on board, and four months of lost wages for the crew, around $120,000 in total.
不过最终，他们彻底从雷达上消失了，穆罕默德再也没有听到他们的消息。幸运的是，这艘船有保险，穆罕默德开始游说他们提供帮助。ITF 施加了压力。通过向保险公司施加压力，他们为我们争取到了四个月的工资。ITF 做到了这一点。穆罕默德让保险公司支付了船上被困海员的基本物资费用，以及船员四个月的失业工资，总计约 12 万美元。
But when he began to arrange for the seafarers to go home, he ran into a wall of complications from the Egyptian port authorities. They didn't want to risk the ship being left in the port unmanned and totally abandoned, because then it'd become their problem. Ultimately, Mehmet's ship's case went to court in Egypt. Muhammad's organization,
但当他开始安排海员回家时，他遇到了来自埃及港口当局的一堵由各种复杂情况组成的高墙。他们不想冒险让船只在无人看管和完全废弃的情况下留在港口，因为那样就会变成他们的问题。最终，穆罕默德的船的案子在埃及对簿公堂。穆罕默德的组织——
the ITF, appointed and paid for their lawyer. And then, after seven months of Muhammad and the crew trudging through this bureaucracy, hundreds of phone calls and WhatsApp messages, court dates and dead ends and a few false starts, it was decided that most of the seafarers should be allowed to leave in phases. Mehmet gives a ton of credit to Muhammad and the ITF for finally getting them off of the ship. I mean, if it wasn't for ITF, you would probably have been doomed. Maybe I'll still be there.
ITF，指定并支付了他们的律师费用。然后，经过穆罕默德和船员们在这些官僚作风中艰难跋涉了七个月，经历了数百个电话和 WhatsApp 消息、出庭日期、死胡同和几次虚假开始后，决定应该分阶段允许大多数船员离开。穆罕默德对穆罕默德和 ITF 最终让他们下船表示了极大的赞赏。我的意思是，如果不是 ITF，你们可能就死定了吧。也许我还会在那里。
Maybe you would have to stay for another six months. In the last week of December, right before Christmas, Mehmet finally stepped off the Keenan-Methae in Egypt and got on a flight home to surprise his family. I didn't want to get their hopes up, so not to destroy their hopes, I didn't tell them. I made it to surprise. Eventually, all but one of the crew members onboard the Keenan Meta were repatriated to
也许你还得再待六个月。12月的最后一周，就在圣诞节前夕，穆罕默德终于走下了埃及的“基南·麦塔号”，搭上了回家的航班，去给他的家人一个惊喜。我不想给他们太高的期望，为了不打破他们的希望，我没有告诉他们。我制造了一个惊喜。最终，“基南·麦塔号”上除了一个人之外的所有船员都被遣返回
their various home countries. But the situation still hasn't been totally resolved. Because of the rules in Egypt, the captain is still there, but he has been moved to a hotel near the port. Muhammad told me that the captain won't be able to go home until the ship has been auctioned off to a new owner, a process that could take several more months. These days, Mahmet is trying to figure out how to earn a living in Odessa, Ukraine, where he lives. If he can possibly avoid it, he never wants to set foot on another cargo ship again.
他们各自的祖国。但情况仍未完全解决。由于埃及的规定，船长仍然留在那里，但他被转移到了港口附近的一家酒店。穆罕默德告诉我，在船被拍给新船主之前，船长无法回家，这个过程可能还需要几个月的时间。如今，穆罕默德正试图在居住地乌克兰敖德萨寻找谋生之道。如果可能的话，他再也不想踏上另一艘货轮。
After all this happened, I'm going to do whatever I have to do as far as I can. I'm not thinking of going back to ships. I have aged three or five years. I mean, I feel that. I know that, too. Before I joined the ship, I was really good. My appearance, stuff was good. But after I went through like this, I feel like I got old when I look in the mirror. The Met's case was actually not as drawn out as other people I spoke to for this story.
发生了这一切之后，只要我能做到，我会尽我所能。我没打算再回船上去了。我已经老了三五岁。我的意思是，我能感觉到这一点。我也知道。上船之前，我状态真的很好。我的外表、各方面都很好。但经历了这一切之后，当我照镜子时，我觉得自己变老了。穆罕默德的案子实际上并不像我为这个故事采访的其他人的经历那么漫长。
There was Vikash who spent nearly three years on a ship off the coast of the United Arab Emirates before he could get off. And Samik, whose crew was stuck off the coast of the United Arab Emirates before he could get off, and Samik, whose crew were stuck off the coast of Beirut for over a year, and in their case, they were living on a ship that most of the time had no electricity. Andy from Mission to Sea Ferris told me that one reason all of this takes so long to resolve is that the owners are trying to get the best price possible when they sell their ship, because they owe so many different people money. What sometimes happens is they say, well, the market is depressed at the moment, but markets
有维卡什（Vikash），他在阿拉伯联合酋长国海岸附近的一艘船上度过了将近三年才得以离开；还有萨米克（Samik），他的船员被困在贝鲁特海岸附近超过一年，而在他们的情况下，他们生活在一艘大部分时间没有电的船上。“海员使命”的安迪告诉我，所有这一切需要这么长时间才能解决的一个原因，是因为船东在出售船只时试图获得尽可能最好的价格，因为他们欠了太多不同人的钱。有时发生的情况是，他们会说，好吧，现在的市场低迷，但市场
do fluctuate, so if we wait another six months, perhaps the market will improve and therefore we can get more for our ship And they tend to not think about the crew who will have to sit on the ship floating during that period of time Andy's working on a new law in the United Arab Emirates that would give port authorities power to take ownership of a vessel 60 days after abandonment That way they could auction it off and the seafarers could go home much quicker abandonment, that way they could auction it off and the seafarers could go home much quicker. If countries can enact regulations that ban things like flags of convenience and strengthen labor unions, that will also help ship abandonment cases go down. These are the
是会波动的，所以如果我们再等六个月，也许市场会有所改善，因此我们能为我们的船卖出更高的价钱。而他们往往不会去想到那些必须在那段期间坐在随波逐流的船上的船员。安迪正在阿拉伯联合酋长国致力于一项新法律，该法律将赋予港口当局在船只被遗弃 60 天后接管船舶所有权的权力。这样他们就可以将其拍卖，海员们就能更快地回家。如果各国能够颁布禁止方便旗等行为并加强工会的法规，也将有助于减少船只遗弃案件。这些都是
kinds of things that have already made abandonment relatively rare in Europe and the US. But until more of those bigger structural changes occur, the work for people like Muhammad and Andy will happen one ship at a time. Here we are, just a few miles out on yet another abandoned vessel. And we're just going to meet a couple of the crew. We're going to have a cup of tea with them
已经在欧洲和美国使船只遗弃变得相对罕见的那类事情。但在更多这些更大的结构性改变发生之前，像穆罕默德和安迪这样的人的工作将是一艘船一艘船地进行。现在我们在这里，在几英里外的又一艘被遗弃的船上。我们正要去见几个船员。我们要和他们喝杯茶，
or drink some coffee or glass of cold water and just remind them that people are still thinking about them. This episode was produced by Alex Aitak and edited by Katie Mingle, owner, Akma Met, voiced from a Met's interview, started thanks to Charles Mainz and Delora Chellock. This episode was made in collaboration with Karning Cultures, that's Karning with a K. It's a podcast that makes audio stories like this one from the Middle East and North Africa.
或者喝点咖啡、一杯凉水，只是提醒他们，人们还在想着他们。本集节目由亚历克斯·埃塔克制作，凯蒂·明格尔编辑，奥马尔·阿克玛·麦特（音）为穆罕默德的采访配音，感谢查尔斯·迈因茨和德洛拉·切洛克提供的帮助。本集节目是与《克朗文化》（Karning Cultures，Karning 以 K 开头）合作制作的。这是一个播客节目，制作像这样来自中东和北非的音频故事。
When we come back, an abandoned ship starts a chain of events that ends in a huge tragedy. So producer Alex A.Tac is back and he's going to tell us how the massive explosion in a port in BeRoot in August of 2020 was connected to an abandoned ship. Yeah, so in November 2013, an old rusty worn out ship called the MV Rosas arrived at the port in downtown BeRoot carrying about 2,750 tons of this highly explosive fertilizer called ammonium nitrate. Yeah. So, not long after it arrived at the Port in Beirut, the ship was impounded by the Lebanese port authorities because basically it had quite a lot of things wrong with it.
当我们回来时，一艘被遗弃的船引发了一连串事件，最终导致了一场巨大的悲剧。制作人亚历克斯·A·塔克回来了，他将为我们讲述 2020 年 8 月贝鲁特港口的大规模爆炸是如何与一艘被遗弃的船只联系在一起的。是的，所以在 2013 年 11 月，一艘又旧又破、磨损严重的名为“罗萨斯号”（MV Rosas）的船抵达了贝鲁特市中心的港口，船上载有约 2,750 吨这种高爆炸性化肥——硝酸铵。是的。所以，在它抵达贝鲁特港后不久，这艘船就被黎巴嫩港口当局扣押了，因为基本上它有很多问题。
A few crew members had to stay on board because, as you know, as we mentioned in the story, it's not legal for seafarers to just get off these ships and leave whatever is it on the ship, like unattended or unmanned as they call it in the port. Right. And so eventually the ship's owner, this Russian guy called Igo Gorkushkin, he went dark, stopped replying to emails, didn't answer phone calls.
有几个船员不得不留在船上，因为如你所知，正如我们在故事中提到的那样，海员擅自下船并将船上的任何东西置之不理是不合法的，也就是港口里所说的那种无人看管或无人在船的状态。没错。所以最终船的拥有者，这个名叫伊戈尔·戈库什金（Igor Gorkushkin）的俄罗斯人，失联了，不再回复电子邮件，也不接听电话。
Yeah, that's they do. Yeah, that's they do. His la lai chalili, who you heard in the story. Actually, the seafarers end up sitting on that ship for something like 10 months with all of that ammonium nitrate, essentially on a floating bomb. Oh my god. Yeah, and then after a court case, the ship's crew were eventually allowed to leave and they flew back home to Ukraine, which basically left the Lebanese authorities in charge of the dangerous cargo, and it was moved into a hangar in the port.
是的，他们总是这样。是的，他们总是这样。这是你在故事中听到的拉勒·哈利利。实际上，船员们最终在那艘船上待了大约 10 个月，带着所有的硝酸铵，本质上就像坐在一个浮动的炸弹上。哦，天哪。是的，然后经过一场法庭诉讼，船上的船员最终被允许离开并飞回乌克兰，这基本上让黎巴嫩当局负责处理危险货物，它被转移到了港口的一个机库里。
So the cargo was moved, but what happened to the actual ship itself? Yeah, so the ship just fell into disrepair, like it stayed where it was in the port and sank. Because as we mentioned in the story, like ships need this, you know, they need this kind of round the clock labor force, you know, constantly maintaining it to keep them in good shape.
所以货物被转移了，那艘船本身怎么样了？是的，所以这艘船就年久失修了，就像它停在港口里的地方一样沉下去了。因为正如我们在故事中提到的，船只需要这个，你知道，它们需要这种全天候的劳动力，你知道，不断地维护它以保持良好的状态。
And if they don't have that, they'll sink really quickly. That's amazing. I didn't know that the war on entropy was so constant and unrelenting. I mean, you mentioned it, but really, it just takes a few years and a ship just goes straight down. Yeah, I had no idea about that either. So the ship is at the bottom of the port, but all the explosive ammonium nitrate is in a hanger.
如果没有这些，它们很快就会沉没。这太神奇了。我不知道对抗熵增的过程竟然如此持续且毫不留情。我的意思是，你提到了，但实际上，只需要几年时间，一艘船就会直接沉下去。是的，我对此也一无所知。所以船在港口底部，但所有爆炸性的硝酸铵都在机库里。
Yeah, just kept in a hanger in the port. It sat there basically for seven years unattended, and I mean, pretty much forgotten about, except for a small number of port officials and port staff. And there were warnings that it wasn't safe for it to just be sitting there in the state that it was in, and those warnings were constantly ignored by the authorities. Yeah, and it was not safe at all. Much of Beirut is shattered this morning by one of the most powerful peacetime explosions ever.
是的，就那样放在港口的一个机库里。它在那里基本上待了七年，无人看管，我的意思是，几乎被遗忘了，除了少数港口官员和港口工作人员。而且曾有警告称，它就这样以那种状态放在那里是不安全的，而这些警告不断被当局忽视。是的，而且一点也不安全。今天早晨，贝鲁特的大部分地区被和平时期有史以来最强烈的爆炸之一摧毁了。
Look closely and you can see what happened. This is the port as a fire rages popping and sparking. The flames swell to a noisy roar until the second blast. Other angles show the blast. Yeah, August 4th, 2020, a small fire broke out in a hangar nearby where the ammonium nitrate was being stored. It made its way into the hangar and the ammonium nitrate caught fire and exploded. It was an incredibly powerful blast. About 200 people died and thousands more were injured.
仔细看，你能看到发生了什么。这是港口燃起大火，发出爆裂声和火花的场景。火焰膨胀成喧闹的轰鸣声，直到第二次爆炸发生。其他角度展示了爆炸。是的，2020年8月4日，存放硝酸铵的附近机库爆发了一场小火。火势蔓延到机库，硝酸铵起火并发生了爆炸。这是一次极其强烈的爆炸。大约 200 人死亡，数千人受伤。
It basically leveled the whole part of the city near the port. There were reports that the blast tremors were felt as far away as cypress, which is about 150 miles away from Beirut. Wow. I mean, it's incredibly awful. And I was, I guess I didn't really know that it started with an abandon ship. I, you know, I, I'd heard about the Amonium Nitrate being stored. I knew that that was unsafe, but I didn't know why.
它基本上夷平了港口附近整片城市。有报道称，连远在距离贝鲁特约 150 英里的塞浦路斯都能感受到爆炸的震颤。哇。我的意思是，这真是太可怕了。我猜我真的不知道它是由一艘被遗弃的船开始的。我，你知道，我听说过硝酸铵被储存起来。我知道这不安全，但我不知道为什么。
Yeah, I mean, obviously this is like a worst-case scenario, but I think it really does like illustrate why Port Authority's don't want the crew to leave these ships unmanned because Then the ship and everything on it really does become their responsibility to deal with and I mean in this case Like obviously they did an awful job dealing with it But it was their responsibility nonetheless after the crew left. Yeah, I mean, it has a whole new element to the consequence of this abandoned ship story that what's on the ship, you know, could be really dangerous and has to be dealt with with those countries. And so you kind of understand their position a little bit more as to why they can't just take on whatever is left for them
是的，我的意思是，显然这是一个最坏的情况，但我认为它确实说明了为什么港口当局不希望船员离开这些船只而无人看管，因为那样的话，这艘船以及上面的所有东西真的就成了他们必须处理的责任，我的意思是，在这个案子里，显然他们处理得非常糟糕，但不管怎样，在船员离开后，这依然是他们的责任。是的，我的意思是，这为这个被遗弃船只的故事的后果增添了一个全新的元素，即船上的东西，你知道，可能真的很危险，必须由这些国家来处理。所以你有点更能理解他们的立场，为什么他们不能只是接手任何由一些无良船东留给他们的东西。
by some unscrupulous ship owner. Yeah, yeah, absolutely. So after this mirrored explosion, did that change a little the dynamics of the abandoned ships? It definitely brought a lot more attention to the plight of like other crews who are abandoned on ships and also just like the issue of abandoned ships in general. From what I can tell it hasn't led to any like material changes in legislation,
是的，是的，绝对是这样。那么在这场贝鲁特爆炸之后，这是否在一定程度上改变了被遗弃船只的动态？它确实引起了人们对被遗弃在船上的其他船员的困境以及一般意义上的被遗弃船只问题的更多关注。据我所知，它尚未在黎巴嫩或中东其他地方引发任何实质性的立法变革，以在被遗弃船只案件发生之前帮助阻止它们。谢谢你给我们带来这个故事，亚历克斯，我真的很感激。谢谢你，罗曼。本周的 99% Invisible 由亚历克斯·埃塔克制作，凯蒂·明格尔编辑，阿米塔·加纳特拉（Amita Ganatra）混音，音乐由我们的声音总监肖恩·里亚尔（Sean Rial）创作。德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colstead）是数字总监，团队的其他成员还有埃姆特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、拉舍马·多恩（Lashemadon）、克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Baroube）、薇薇安·勒（Vivian Le）、索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）以及我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是 Stitcher 和 Sirius XM 播客家族的一部分。目前总部设在北部六个街区外。
in Lebanon or elsewhere in the Middle East, to kind of help stop abandoned shipcases before they happen. Thank you for bringing this story to us, Alex, I really appreciate it. Thanks, Roman. 99% of us were produced this week by Alex A. Tech, edited by Katie Mingle, mixed by Amita Ganatra, music by our director of Sound Sean Rial. Delaney Hall is the executive producer, Kurt Colstead is the digital director, the rest of the team, is Emmett Fitzgerald, Joe Rosenberg, Christopher Johnson, Lashemadon, Chris Baroube, Vivian Le, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are a part of this Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family. Now headquartered six blocks north.
位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰美丽的上城区。你可以在 Facebook 上找到这个节目并参与关于它的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@Roman Mars 或者@999PI Orc 找我。我们在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上。你可以在我们的网站 9iNiPI.org 上找到我从 Stitcher 喜欢的其他节目，包括《阿特拉斯·奥布斯卡播客》（Atlas Obscura podcast），这是一个对世界上奇怪而奇妙的地方的简短每日赞颂。最后，访问 99pi.org 可以收听 99PI 的每一个往期节目。他们还没有给我提供合适的音频标志，所以……嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟……目前这个节目还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。
In beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show in Dorn Discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars on the show at 999PI Orc. We're on Instagram and ready to. You can find other shows I love from Stitcher on our website, 9iNiPI.org, including the Atlas Obscura podcast, a short daily celebration of the world's strange and wondrous places. Finally, to it, in every past episode of 99PI at 99pi.org. They still haven't gotten me that proper audio logo, so... Tududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududududud There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在美丽的花旗加州奥克兰上城区。你可以在Facebook上的Dorn Discussions找到这个节目。你可以在Twitter上@Roman Mars，或在@99pi.org找到本节目。我们在Instagram上也随时恭候。你可以在我们的网站99pi.org上找到我从Stitcher精选的其他喜爱节目，包括Atlas Obscura播客，这是一个关于世界上奇异美妙之地的每日简短颂歌。最后，请在99pi.org上收听99PI的每一期往期节目。他们还没给我做那个像样的音频标志，所以... 嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟... 这期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。